really cool charity hockey game this
weekend will go a long way to help
veterans with medical sponsorships the
coast to coast foundation and vegas
veterans hockey foundation are hosting
the game at city national arena it's
part of the foundation's ride for the
fallen a 4 000 mile cross-country
journey from la to arlington national
cemetery several vets former nhl and
european players and our own john
langler will participate each player
will wear a jersey with the name of a
military member who made the ultimate
sacrifice something that makes this game
that much more special
there's nothing more more great than you
know watching your brothers and sisters
out on the ice
and having the opportunity to wear a
jersey that represents each one of those
fallen heroes and when that name goes on
you're on your back and you you know
that you're representing that fallen
soldier
it's meaningful and it's impactful
coast to coast is a non-profit
organization that provides medical
sponsorships for veterans of the special
ops community puck drop for the game is
1 pm tomorrow tickets are 10 kids 13
under are free all proceeds go to the
vets